he's done miracles on me
he's done miracles on me kim kardashian
just rocked a wedding dress to kanye
west's latest donda listening party and
needless to say the whole thing has
people talking i mean it was just fun to
go on and just do something for my heart
on thursday the 44 year old rapper
hosted another donda listening party at
soldier field in his hometown of chicago
and after surprising fans with some
unannounced guests and unexpected
additions to his tracks kanye upped the
drama when he lit himself on fire
[Music]
and while fans watching the live
streamed event thought that was the
grand finale they thought wrong because
after kanye was extinguished a woman who
appeared to be his estranged wife kim
dressed in a balenciaga wedding gown
complete with a long white veil joined
him on the ground as traditional wedding
music played over the loudspeakers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
of course the reality star filed for
divorce from kanye after six years of
marriage in february so fans had a lot
to say about the moment on twitter
[Music]
one user wrote quote so did he set
himself on fire to get rid of his sins
and became a new man with kim kardashian
another commented quote kim and kanye
are the weirdest divorcing couple i've
ever seen well someone else asked the
big question on everyone's mind did
kanye and kim just get back together him
and i have been best friends for a
really long time and just been in each
other's lives kim's sisters khloe
kardashian and kylie jenner also shared
the surprising moment posting pics and
clips to their insta stories
[Music]
et has confirmed that the woman was in
fact kim but according to reports kim
and yay are not back on tmz says the
wedding ceremony was simply part of the
performance on friday a source provided
some insight saying kim and kanye are on
great terms quote although they are
going through a divorce the couple still
spend time together alone or with their
kids kanye lives mostly out of la but
when he's in town they make it a
priority to meet up kim has had the
children lately since kanye has been
working on the album but co-parenting
has been going well for the couple
you